jede frau ist eine prostituierte auch
die die sich vor einem chef im büro
nicht macht und findet im eigentlich
schlecht street herzlich konzern will
leute ich war heute wieder unterwegs und
da habe ich ein video gefunden bei dem
ich mir gedacht habe warte warte das
kann jetzt nicht ernst seit das video
heißt wie eigentlich einen millionär und
dreht sich rund um eine frau irina die
sich selbst ein millionär gehandelt hat
und jetzt auch anderen frauen dabei
helfen will wie sie gezielt einen
reichen mann suchen und denen dann von
sich überzeugen
dann sind wir ganz ehrlich das erwecke
den eindruck als wenn die einzige aufbau
von männern frauen geld zu geben und das
einzige ziel von frauen im leben wert
möglichst reichen mann zu finden also
haben wir schon relativ günstiges video
leute schaut mal rein
sie hat ihr ziel erreicht leben im luxus
ohne zu arbeiten
denn die juwelen die luxusautos und die
teuren klamotten zahlt er mister rich ok
ja dass wir auf der linken seite ist
dann vermutlich irina ich lese ich
nochmal kurzen text aus der beschreibung
vor ort vom aschenputtel zur
multi-millionärin durch die heirat mit
einem vermögenden bauunternehmer sonnt
sich irina ein luxus die ukrainerin
verrät uns die man sich erfolgreich ein
mystery checks
[Musik]
also ich hoffe hofft er hoffe dass in
diesen beitrag noch ein bisschen mehr
facetten von bei der partnerwahl genannt
werden als er den kontostand aber sonst
was hier aus die an
ich warte ich warte nach wie vor auf
einen moment in dem gesagt wird ja okay
ich finde auch seine finanzielle
tragkraft interessant und attraktiv aber
nicht nur das sondern abc.de soweit es
einfach nur mit einfach mit mascha
einfach mister rich die als trainerin
hat sich den 50 millionen euro schweren
bauunternehmer mit voller absicht
gehandelt und steht dazu ganze zwei
leute also wir sind noch nicht allzu
tief in diesem video sind erst 30
sekunden aber an der stelle erst mal ein
vorläufiges ein vorläufiges rest in
peace für unseren bruder hier auf der
rechten seite der in diesem wasser bis
dato noch nichts gesagt hat und der
einfach accessoire genannt wird inas es
war wie eine fackel drei euro fuß kette
die irgendeine chantal auf ibiza kauft
liebt ihre in einem sack voller geld
oder den mann und das luxusweibchen red
nun sogar in einem buch anderen frauen
ihre zeit nicht mit einem armen
schlucker zu verplempern
ok jetzt jetzt langsam jetzt langsam
wird's uci heute langsam wird's taktik
denn ganz ehrlich jeder mensch kann in
seinem eigenen leben in gewissen grenzen
da ist manchmal die grenze die würde von
anderen menschen oder das wohlbefinden
von anderen menschen kann jeder mensch
für sich selbst entscheiden was in
seinem leben machen möchte aber sie geht
noch einen schritt weiter und gibt jetzt
scheinbar ein coaching darüber wie man
ein millionär handelt 200
[Musik]
ja ja wir also alle alle männer männer
sind ähnlich ok maybe alle frauen sind
auch ähnlich muss man allerdings
aussagen der letzten endes sind wir alle
irgendwo eine gewisse ausprägung eines
nachfahren verwarfen und ähneln uns
natürlich ist ja klar aber dieser hat
diese argumentation ist schon dies schon
uci alter okay dass ich sage jetzt mal
wirklich was was von herzen wenn ihr
leute treffen die so krass auf
materialismus aus den so krass auf geld
aus sind deren welt sich so krass um
solche dinge dritte geld materialismus
whatever seid vorsichtig seid vorsichtig
vor 14 jahren heiratete die heute 41
jährige irina bella ihren meister rage
und seitdem hat sie fette beute gemacht
der beute gehört erobert das ist
wirklich die ganz falsche wort es geht
hier immer noch um einen bund fürs leben
um eine partnerschaft die man fürs leben
eingeht okay wie kann man darüber in
worten wie beute machen reden ganz
ehrlich das hat in diesem kontext nichts
zu suchen für mich zumindest persönlich
aber andererseits muss ich auch sagen so
mein persönliches bauchgefühl sagt mir
wenn wir hier einen unternehmer haben
der es geschafft hat sich ein vermögen
von 50 millionen euro aufzubauen denn
wird ja auch schlau genug sein sich
nicht von seiner frau über den tisch
ziehen zu lassen kanal verkatert drei
andere frauen also ich weiß es nicht
also auch das auto eben geschenk ihres
mannes ja okay leute ok mal ganz kurz
meine gedanken dazu ich finde persönlich
weiß nicht was eure erfahrung zu diesem
thema sind es ist schwer genug im leben
einen menschen zu finden der einen
wirklich versteht also mit man nicht mit
dem man so irgendwie zeit verbringen
kann so ein mensch der einen wirklich
fleisch wenn man sagt digger grafs
dieser mensch schockt mich auf eine sehr
positive art und weise mit dem möchte
ich mehr zeit verbringen das ist einfach
anders als bei allen anderen ok schwer
genug schwer genug wieder was diese
wahrscheinlichkeit dass dieser mensch
auch noch stinkreich ist ich würde sagen
zero also würde ich jetzt vielleicht mal
daraus schlussfolgern dass sie
vielleicht die priorität geld ein
bisschen höher angesetzt hat als die
priorität wie vertragen sich unsere
charaktere harmonieren wir gut
ob das jetzt die beste entscheidung fürs
leben ist weiß ich auch nicht er ina
weller hatte ihren mann vom juwelier
beordert der gatte wartete dort schon
brav mit ernährungs fahrer die armaturen
und frau bella griff beherzt zu einer
hoch leute nur mit diamanten aber bitte
mal kann er bitte mal zu wort kommen
hier egal dass ich bin gefällt wirklich
dieses bild überhaupt nicht was sie
gezeichnet wird der hintergrundstory
ihre uhr ist kaputt gegangen und zeigt
wie richtig die uhrzeit an erste
reaktion ist natürlich nicht mit der un
dazu gehen sie zu reparieren nein es
wird neu gekauft und zwar in welcher art
und weise dass der mann in den laden
bestellt wird der mann ist scheinbar
bauunternehmer mit 50 millionen business
aber hat schon mal nichts zu tun und
kommt einfach wenn seine frau sagt
schatz war okay lustig es war die bibel
zur freude spielen wir kurz zurück
achtet auf sein gesicht heute fokussiert
euch auf sein gesicht und achtet darauf
welche immense freude dieser mann ist in
diesem moment empfindet er ist einfach
ein ausrasten
nein ganz ehrlich ich fühle dass auch
sich für die eigene freundin zu sorgen
so dieses versorger ding das habe ich
auf jeden fall auch sein dass feiere ich
auch sonst finde ich cool ja dass ich
weiß nicht ob das jetzt hier so richtig
cool und irina penner sagt alle frauen
wollen eine message in ihrem buch gibt
sie relativ banale tipps die aber
angeblich direkt vor den traualtar mit
einem superreichen führen okay okay
alle frauen wollen einen mister rich
okay sagt sie ganz im ernst heute wenn
man die priorität geld so hoch ansetzen
da muss man an anderen stellen
gravierende abstriche machen und ist
dann sein ganzes leben
höchstwahrscheinlich mit dem team
zusammen 90 prozent von den fällen der
persönlich zu einem nicht passt und kann
dafür hat ein bisschen tragen sie leben
durchgespielt tipp nummer zwei wenn du
die aufmerksamkeit des millionenschweren
opfer saß dann führte ihn an aber nur
für auf keinen fall mehr
es kann deutlich sei es kann nicht seit
diese frau will leuten beibringen wie
man sich einen millionär einig und
spricht von den männern als opfer opfer
digger was ist dass selbst eine kranke
sicht auf die welt als mp3 und sichere
den erstens sehr lange raus ok ja ja ja
ja okay da wo sich wiederum sagen leute
ich bin heute einfach straight und
ehrlich mit euch das kann schon das bild
was ein mann von einer frau hat negativ
prägen ist ganz einfach so ich glaube
dass ich zumindest in meinem
persönlichen umfeld fact so viele von
euch wissen vielleicht auch selbst schon
im eigenen leben heutzutage 2020 sind
die verhältnisse relativ crazy und
manche leute drehen vollkommen durch
wenn man die sache ein bisschen schlauer
angeht kann das durchaus vernünftig sein
und kann dem anderen zeigen hey da ist
eine person die keine an dass irgendeine
sache auch von selbst respekt wenn ich
teilweise kann am rad frau ihren mister
rich dann aber
geheiratet hat seinen wert so berechnet
irina bella bestimmte praktiken mit
schmuck im wert von 20.000 euro leute
meinen kopf mein schreibtisch schropp
schraub schraub oder warte wird kay
losgesagt
[Musik]
normal muss mindestens ein boutique
besucher und wir fragen uns ist das
nicht einfach nur eine form von
prostitution ja ja ja wie kann man denn
so an seine ehe herangehen bro'sis es
ist eine ehe sollte es dann mit einem
menschen zusammenkommen der dich
zuschauer irgendwie eine bessere
menschen macht aber nicht weil dir die
teure uhr oder was auch immer kauft
sondern weil er irgendwie ergänzt weil
ihr euch gegenseitig helfen und sie ist
[Musik]
prostitution sich auch gut finde jede
frau ist eine prostituierte auch die die
sich vor einem chef im büro nicht macht
und findet ihn eigentlich schlecht
[Musik]
street straight 77 so niebel
so nämlich also der talk ich in meiner
meinung nach ist das mit der
gravierendste schrott den ich in den
letzten wochen überhaupt gesehen habe
hat mir auch mal gern nach unten die
kommentare check hier einfach ich
vorgeschlagen das video abonniert hier
oben ein millionär den herausnehmen
können bleibt stabil bleibt
prostituierte bis zum nächsten mal